zombies
who could have guessed that when the
undead first appeared in call of duty
world at war
it would lead us here to today from that
moment
zombies sparked a love for fighting the
undead bringing its unique dna to the
call of duty experience
whether you're playing solo or co-op
working to solve puzzles or unlock
easter eggs
facing wave after wave of the undead
delivers fast fun action with just one
objective
survive black ops cold war sets the
stage for a new zombies experience
that not only celebrates our entire
zombie's heritage but uses it
as an inspiration to build a completely
new chapter in our universe
today we'll cover the characters the
backstory and weapons
with members of the development team
some of whom have quite literally helped
to build it one zombie at a time
but first let's check out the worldwide
premiere of our new
zombies gameplay trailer
fam what have you done did you get the
package
watch it watch the tape
what the hell is that
[Applause]
it's happening again requiem actual
strike team is on the ground
investigate the site contain the threat
roger moving
let's get the power on what was that
[Music]
sometimes
let's go
[Music]
take my tears
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
on the way
[ __ ] did you see that
[Music]
back the [ __ ] off you can't kill me
after so many journeys so many chapters
with black ops cold war
we're starting fresh embarking on a
completely different story within our
universe
we've got a new story led by different
characters
we've got new ways to play anchored by
new ways of progressing
we've got a different time period cold
war zombies wasn't just our opportunity
to open up a different chapter
it was our opportunity to elevate the
entire zombies experience
it's a chapter we call the machine
as we set out to build something
completely new we were inspired to pay
homage to zombies undead roots to
celebrate
our origin with one of our most familiar
and signature locations
[Music]
we finished a story but we're still in
that same
universe and this is the next chapter
the the very end of black ops 4
our characters sacrificed themselves to
collapse the multiverse and
try and create a singular world where
zombies didn't exist
and they were half right
this is a cold war story and it will be
driven by a diverse group of
organizations and characters
players are part of requiem a ci-backed
international response team led by
weaver
a russian american who will be familiar
to black ops fans
by the time you arrive on the hunt for
answers d machina will have been ravaged
by time
on the surface you'll see a boarded up
bunker
but below the surface lies a nefarious
set of decades-old secrets
primed to upset the global order
the players will find themselves at odds
with a team of soviet-led rivals known
as omega group
who are just as interested in studying
and harnessing the power of the
unexplained anomalies
manifesting around the globe beyond
these two warring groups they'll
encounter characters with unknown
agendas who operate in the field
delivering insights and intel on this
new world's fiction
the intel you receive and recover is a
huge component of our storytelling in
cold war
and for the first time an innovative new
intel system will make
content accessible on demand anytime
there's a lot to uncover that no one's
ever seen before
let's get into the gameplay that starts
with delivering all your favorite
elements
relentless round-based action the
pack-a-punch machine power-up drops
the mystery box along with the return of
some of our classic perks
we've also taken a fresh eye to the core
gameplay loop to let you drop in
and have fun faster than ever the
gameplay is classic
but it's going to be totally quite fresh
you'll find our updates this year have
focused
on one thing above all embracing what
makes zombies so much fun
that starts with progression this year
we have unified progression and loadouts
across
all of call of duty black ops cold war
that means wherever you play across
multiplayer zombies your global rank and
weapons level stays connected
you'll be unlocking weapons and
equipment score streaks that will be
usable across the entirety of the game
no more starting with a pistol
bring in your ar your smg whatever
you're feeling
and with all weapons boasting rarity
with power levels you can continue to
increase your gun's damage potential
however you choose every gun has a path
to become an uber weapon you'll have a
lethal
tactical and support slot not only can
you craft
pick up or find equipment and support in
zombies but you can now
use them in combination which delivers
some insanely fun moments
traditionally in zombies the only way
out was death our new x-fil system
solves this things get tense and the
squad is in trouble
you have the option to expel to a
chopper and earn some rewards but only
if you can survive a few more rounds of
zombie spawns dialed up to 11.
this is shaping up to be our most epic
zombies experience
ever for the first time post launch
content is going to be free
as new maps come out everyone's going to
be able to come along for the journey as
we take them through this storyline
lastly canon is canon and we've put a
story to rest
but as you comb through this new
universe don't be surprised if
some things don't want to stay dead
this is the most connected and robust
zombies experience in history
it also delivers a first for zombies a
fully cross-play experience
with progression systems that tie
zombies to the battle pass
we're dropping free post-launch zombies
content to the community for the first
time as well
we're honored to have you with us on
this journey we're glad that you could
join us
for today's first look
you